i want to talk about a couple of uh very
extreme examples right and i'll start
kind of on two different ends of the
spectrum
there's a lot of people that would say
uh
great the federal government can print
as much money as they want
they should do that they're kind of
centrally planned uh type economy
print as much as you need spend it how
you see fit
and help us be economically stable
but if you can print your own money why
do i pay taxes
right it's kind of like remove one side
of the balance sheet if you will or your
p
l and on the other side just like go at
it
i'm assuming that you disagree one with
that and also two
it's the long-term effect which is kind
of how do you think about that extreme
argument and then we'll flip around and
talk about the other side of it
yes so this is like one of the big
pieces of
like the mmt narrative that i think is
very very wrong this idea that they
they like to claim that taxes don't fund
spending
um that because the government has a
printing press that they
they don't need underlying revenue
sources and i just think
they're kind of playing word games with
a lot of this i think the
the tax revenue that a government
generates is a
function of its output okay and
any underlying economy needs output in
order to have
viable money the only reason people want
money is because they really want the
stuff
that they can get with money they don't
really want the money
they really want the stuff that money
gives them access to and so you need the
stuff
to make the money valuable you know you
can't the
it's putting the cart before the horse
to get that backwards and so
um in terms of the
the government and its tax revenues
the government needs tax revenues
because it needs
underlying output that generates the
income that makes
everything valuable so it's like um
you know i like to think of the
government basically like a big bank
the government can create money from
thin air just like a regular bank can
but the the bank needs underlying
assets and income in order to be viable
otherwise nobody would trust that bank
that bank would have no creditors and
the government is really similar in that
the government needs to have underlying
resources
and income to some degree that
make everything viable that makes
everything work
and supports the underlying credit
issuance because that's what the
government really does
the government is just a big issuer of
credit
and the essential aspect of credit is
that
people need to to some degree believe
that that credit is valuable in the long
term otherwise there's no reason for
them to want to hold it and
when you have an economy that starts to
produce less or just um
over time starts to sort of stagnate and
and doesn't have the underlying
productive resources
the credit system becomes inherently
less valuable to the people who are
using it
and you what happens is you get a lower
demand for money which results in
an increase in the rate of inflation
so if we then flip to the other side
there's a bunch of people who would
argue
uh the government is full of people who
have no clue what they're doing
and they should allow the free market to
rain
don't step in don't intervene let boom
and bust cycles occur
uh and your intervention is actually uh
causing bigger problems yeah and so
quantitative
easing is not needed and kind of all of
the other programs how do you think
through that
argument i
there's some truth to that and it's
probably
there's probably too many
generalizations like going back to the
early example of why the uh why the fed
is a thing
capitalist economies with private
banking systems
are for the most part over the course of
an entire business cycle
very efficient i mean banks are much
much better issuers of credit and they
have to
compete and they have to be you know
diligent about
how they issue money because it has to
be profitable in the long run and they
have
you know constraints that they have to
be able to meet and
so private banks are for the most part
very very good things because they
they're kind of
they oversee the credit issuance in the
economy
in a competitive manner in a way that
the government
doesn't or would not do if the
government was running the whole banking
system
the problem with private banking is that
during periods like 2008
or you know the thing that really kicked
off the fed's creation was the panic of
1907 when
the whole banking system crashed and the
interbank system really crashed the
clearing houses crashed and that created
this big knock-on effect
that created a great big depression
basically
because again the banks were scared of
each other and it had all these knock-on
effects that were
were super negative and that
that just doesn't make any sense so so
banks in these very
like acute situations are bad
at operating a banking system basically
and it doesn't make sense to
allow that banking system to exacerbate
everything into a depression just
because they get scared of each other so
the fed's
core operational exist reason for
existing
to me makes a lot of sense that in a
period like 2008 the fed
did basically its core job really well
all the tangential stuff the the
changing interest rates and the qe stuff
that was all tangential to the fact that
they actually kept the banking system
really liquid
so they made sure that me and your
businesses didn't fail
because jp morgan and bank of america
couldn't clear a payment so
that core function is really essential
and i think that the
the government has you know a lot of
various operations that it does well
because capitalists aren't willing to do
everything all the time like we're not
capitalists aren't willing to
necessarily
put out fires because putting out fires
isn't very profitable it's hard to make
money you know
putting your employees at risk in that
way and getting people to collectively
pay
insurance to to pay for a fire
department and stuff like that
war is the same sort of thing war has an
inherently negative net present value
because it
it's expensive to build things that get
blown up
and you know go out and kill your
workforce it's hard to make
money running an operation like that so
capitalists
don't want to do these things that have
a sort of negative net present value and
i think those are the those are the
instances where government makes a lot
of sense
the government can do these things that
a
a free market economy just it doesn't
have the incentive structure to do it
because it's just
too damn hard to make money doing those
things but the
where i think the government sometimes
oversteps its boundaries
is where it tries to
[Music]
you know start to do things that start
to
sort of impact the positive net present
value business structure
of of the real economy in a way that
starts to alter it to a degree that
has a negative long-term impact and i
think that
you know it's it's funny like going back
to interest rates like i think that
for the most part the way the fed
changes interest rates in my view
is is for the most part misguided i mean
i think that the fed should basically if
i had it my way
i would take the federal reserve and i
would basically i would peg
the overnight rate at like the core
inflation rate and i would say that
that's just what it is
no more jerome powell saying
you know what do i think the future of
the world is going to look like it would
just be
something automated the bls would come
out with the cpi number
and the overnight number the overnight
interest rate
would change people would earn a real
interest rate
a a real savings rate on something like
treasury bills
um and the whole thing would kind of be
automated
so there is i there's merit to these
arguments where people
say that the fed is sort of you know
sticking their finger in the air and
kind of trying to predict things that
they're not very good at predicting and
in a lot of ways
probably you know if they're not making
things worse they're not necessarily
making things any better